and actually I know someone that went
through this where he was trying to get
like custody of his children and it's
very hard because once if he leaves the
home then she can not let him see like
not let him see his kids for say six
months so with this guy it was like she
kicked him like like they were fighting
whatever he left so because because she
wanted him out of the house I'm gonna
clarify he wanted to be a part of his
kids lives what happened was because of
covet his court date kept moving like
they kept moving it back and what
happened was she went to court and said
he hasn't been around for eight months
he hasn't been around for a year and
he'd been trying the whole time and so
it's like there's a lot of situations
where men want custody of their children
and they can't get it and there's even
men that kill themselves because she
leaves she takes half of their his
assets and he takes the kids and he
doesn't have access to their kids